hi everyone i'm davis guggenheim and i
have the honor to interview and have a
conversation with um the great robert
greene whose film procession is now
hitting theaters and streaming and the
world is starting to take notice it's a
pleasure to talk to you how are you
thanks man thanks how are you doing
good you're in uh missouri right you're
i'm on campus here in columbia missouri
at
uh mizzou here at the missouri school of
journalism yeah yeah robert not only
being a brilliant filmmaker is
runs a the film program there for people
who haven't seen procession i mean it'd
be easy to see that film as one thing
and i won't say what that one thing is
but i'm so curious how you would
describe your movie to someone who's
never seen it
uh and what what what they're about to
watch well there's the you know there's
that that elevator pitch kind of version
which is six survivors come together to
face their own abuse at the hands of
catholic priests when they were children
and they do that by creating these
scenes together which depict rituals of
power
nightmares
other anything they want basically they
try to take power back from the church
that took so much power from them but
the the non-elevator pitch version i
would say is
is it's a it's a film about faith and
brotherhood and family and trying to do
something
um
you know it's a it's a film about what
trauma actually does to you what not not
the not the traumatic event itself we're
not recounting that we're not going into
sort of awful details about what uh
happened to these guys when they were
boys at the hands of you know clergy and
and
catholic clergy but it's a it's it
really is like how it affects you every
single day and um how that what you
could actually do and in our case it is
embracing art therapy it's embracing the
idea that making a movie together um can
be transformative that that actually
creating these scenes going back to
places of abuse um
trying watching someone try to reclaim
power actually can be incredibly
cathartic in and of itself you say uh
making a film together and so many
documentarians say that
yeah you actually did it like explain
that uh
i mean
no i appreciate the documentary say hey
we made this film together and it's kind
of like
you hugged at the end of the shoot
yeah you
it's four years tell us what that the
process is
is groundbreaking and quite
extraordinary i appreciate the way you
frame that yeah i do think there is a
lot of lip service towards collaboration
but here's the truth it's very difficult
to fully collaborate with people that
you're filming with because the truth is
is that there is an old standard of
journalism you know sort of journalistic
practice which is that you need some
separation between the film that you're
making and and the people that you're
filming with that makes a lot of sense
for a lot of films for us it makes no
sense because when we you know i've been
sort of looking for a long time at ways
to be genuinely collaborative rather
than as you rightly put out uh point out
um sort of lip service collaborative
right um
and
early in the process so the way this
whole film came about is uh we had made
bisbee 17 which you executive produced
as well
and someone asked me why i didn't have a
therapist there for the large-scale
recreation of the historically traumatic
event at the center of that film and my
answer was totally inadequate i was not
prepared to answer the question
that got me thinking about what
therapeutic cinema actually looks like
i learned about drama therapy which is
the intentional use of dramatic elements
like theater elements and role play for
therapeutic goals which dovetails
directly with my filmmaking that i've
been doing for many years and i was very
excited about how those two things talk
to each other drama therapy was a way in
to think about the next step for me it
was like hearing learning about trauma
therapy was an amazing thing and and so
i went to rebecca randalls who was the
lawyer for the guys that in the six guys
that end up in the film
and she told me something that was so
important you just can't take their
power away
because that's what they were that was
what happened when they were abused the
the entire the the abuser the entire
system of the church
continually took their power away
one moment after another and you can't
do that and of course my answer is sort
of speaking to you know your your
initial tone there like oh of course i
won't take
but but making a film is all about power
dynamics that's what we we ultimately
had to contend with is how do we focus
this into a thing that is a film that
will help other people and how do we
also make it so it can help the guys
themselves i can testify to the fact
that i was a telluride when the film
premiered
and saw your subjects walking around
telluride and you know their eyes were
wide open at the mountains and they just
they were in a movie
it's incredible but each in their own
way
they embodied
healing there are a lot of movies that
tell you right a lot of movies out now
that are that deal with trauma because i
think it's very
a potent idea because so many
you know the whole country's been
through trauma right
but this is a movie that deals with
trauma and
actually in the process of making it in
the process of
watching it and the process of being a
subject of it even more importantly
people are healed tell that tell us
about how the subjects in your movie
were healed let me just say this nothing
will ever fix
what happened to these guys
they were abused not just by the abuser
but by a belief system that they had
completely bought into or were
indoctrinated into nothing can fix that
but
debilitating aspects of dealing with
shame
and dealing with guilt it's incredible
how much guilt you feel when you're
abused in this way you feel like somehow
it was your fault because this this guy
who did this to you
is considered to be close to god i mean
that is such a upsetting disturbing
you know thing right so every single day
you're dealing with the fact that you
were put in the situation right the
shame of sort of going into a hole into
a dark hole and sort of not connecting
with this and not wanting to talk about
it for your whole life just builds and
builds and builds that's what we could
actually help with so for example
joe
a got one of the six men
has had nightmares for 20-plus years
that that were the the actual catalyst
for him remembering what happened to him
were these nightmares but every single
night even after he had dealt with the
memories and realized that they were
memories he kept having these nightmares
we go back to the lake where a lot of
his abuse happened a lake house and a
place called lake viking and then the
next day his nightmares were gone
which is just the tip of an iceberg
one of the things we realized is these
guys what they needed most was
brotherhood they needed to be believed
they needed to take this thing that had
been rotten inside of them and turn it
into something productive where they
could actually say
no i'm not a victim i'm a survivor i've
actually done something with this i've
actually like made something out of my
own misery so that you the viewer and
other survivors can watch it and get
something at them yourself out of it you
know like they needed to be productive
and that erased the shame as much as
possible and erased nightmares and
erased a lot of the feelings that they
that they've been holding for such a
long time for those who haven't seen the
movie this mike is is like one of the
most injured they're all injured and
traumatized but he talks about how he
hasn't had a relationship his entire
life yeah and you know he see he comes
to tell you right he's seen the movie
and who does he bring with him
his girlfriend his girlfriend and and
and she and she they met when he started
he was working on her deck and then he
started you know talking about hey i'm
in a movie and this is what the movie's
about so literally what led to him
having his first girlfriend of his
entire life and he's in his 50s
what led to that was not being ashamed
of what happened to him
and being proud of making a movie it's
and it seems so obvious it's like just
being proud of yourself just being proud
of what you can do what you've done
together with these other guys i can say
having watched the film
uh not having had this experience uh
that these men have had that it was
healing for me and you might see this
film as one type of film
and it leads to my next question but it
is such it is heavy at times
but also full of joy and laughter and
humanity and i just want to thank you
for giving me that as a viewer i'm so
excited that this is on the academy
site because
it gives me that the chance to talk
about you as a filmmaker and you know
non-fiction gets sort of put in a box
and the great thing is that the last few
years nonfiction has been ripping that
box to shreds
uh and you're one of them i mean you're
what you've been doing
over your last several films has
has been so adventurous
and form-breaking
and cinema at its most beautiful
and i i'm curious
you're a professor of cinema at
university of missouri
if you were robert greene
this is the i don't know
i i hope i don't put you on the spot
here and you were saying oh there's this
guy
robert green over here
and i'm looking at his films
what is the continuum of this guy and
how is his voice
and his process changed over the scope
of this film specifically in this idea
of
performance which i think is a key such
a key thing to your work
yeah for me um
it's just it's about the idea of um
working and sort of perform performance
and documentary this sort of um
contradictory idea performance and
nonfiction when you say it it sounds
either bad or contradictory it's about
being real about what the process
actually is and who
who says yes to being in films and what
can we learn um from actually you know
filming people and editing their stories
together to get at deeper things other
than the surface reality of what we're
seeing what's changed is sort of
realizing for me over the course of my
career realizing that i was interested
in this in the first place i i made a
film called katie with an eye which was
about my sister
and then someone there was a review
written where someone says she gives one
of the best performances of the year and
i realized oh this is more like gray
gardens than it is like primary meaning
what i'm interested more in the way that
she's playing to the camera and sort of
revealing her own um ideas about
adulthood and being a human being in the
world then then i am the actual
interactions of like the day-to-day
interactions she's revealing something
because you can see that she's
performing if i was to look at like
scorsese say well he couldn't have made
good fellows without raging bull sure
and he couldn't have a raging bull
without mean streets right and i look at
um i mean the first film that i saw of
yours was kate plays christine and when
i first saw it i was like what is he
doing here
you film an actress whose job is to play
her yeah and you say okay i'm as
interested in her performance of that to
sort of open up and
and and find something yeah when you
think about procession
we've heard this the headlines countless
times about
about this priest abuse scandal that's
just unfolding it's monumental it's
there's so many victims so many
perpetrators it goes on so big that we
can't truly process it
headlines stories none of it allows us
to process it but when you do
when you find this other method watching
survivors
create their own scenes and then
watching those scenes play out there is
a through line that can be created that
takes us to some other thing meaning i
can't i don't know that i could go and
film someone you know just telling their
story and then like you know talking to
like the officials and i can't do that
but but i know how to make a movie and i
also know the power and the limitations
of of creating these scenes it's just
about deeper realities it's just about
things that can't be said otherwise and
for me it's discovery it's like we've
done that we discovered what it feels
like to conjure the past and bisbee and
how palpable that past becomes in the
present well what do we do now well now
let's give the keys to these survivors
and see what they can do and and so all
that healing just comes from a belief in
the power of movies i know it's that
seems so cheesy but i can't i can't tell
you how true it is it's belief in the
power of images for the viewer but it's
also belief in the power of the the
cathartic act of making the film
together of building something like
these guys all to one degree another are
builders and watching them build is is
phenomenal because we're talking
like you're talking uh
theory and and uh concept but show give
us a visceral
uh um example
of how you built the film together the
scenes themselves
are all co-created by all of us there's
various versions of that michael's
version
in the film is he wants to film the
rituals and symbols so he goes super
deep into the actual physical objects
that we use and then wants to turn that
into a horror movie he literally walked
into a church and you see this in the
film he walks into a church he and dan
are talking
and he just has the moment of idea he's
like oh what if the boy runs to the
balcony and what if everyone turns
around and what if tom who's playing the
priest has the green eyes that are from
joe's nightmares
and then you see us do it and the power
really comes from the fact that michael
has told you why he wants to make that
scene it's about indicting those people
the enablers who are in that church that
they can't see the green eyes but they
they turn in this look at the boy in the
balcony so when you see that scene later
and you've actually seen it before
already in the film the intention mixes
with the images themselves and gives it
this depth of feeling where you're like
this is what a survivor of this abuse
wants me to understand there's that kind
of thing which is very creative and
powerful then there's the kind of thing
where like joe
we're setting up for a confessional
scene basically and the idea was that
michael and joe at the end of the day we
just wanted tom and tarek the boy in the
film just to get dan's lines across dan
dan has you see it in this film in the
film dan has a very specific line that
he would say to not have to talk to the
priest in a confessional
very early on joe says i was abusing a
confessional and we didn't know that
and all of a sudden he had starts having
a convulsive triggering episode
and in that moment it's like all hands
on deck everyone
turns to joe and in that moment it's
either we could just say stop it which
we did we said do you want to stop and
he says no i don't want to stop
and just watching him grab that bull by
the horns and plunge in there he turns
the scene from a simple like delivery of
some lines into
a cathartic experience where it becomes
um clear that he has literally walked
through the darkness and walked back out
i can testify having
seen the film many times but also being
at telluride
that
what you just described is
an incredible experience for everyone in
the theater
and for
i just want to thank you for making this
movie it's
it's great cinema
it's
it does prove that storytelling
has tremendous power it challenges me as
a documentarian to say gosh how how can
i do more and how can i do better you
are breaking
you're breaking rules and breaking
boundaries and changing non-fiction in
the most incredible way it's so
exciting to have this film out in the
world i appreciate it davis thank you so
much thank you for making the film and
uh i encourage everyone who hasn't seen
it to watch it's truly special